he's none of them Jason Stark how are
you Jason rich I'm great how are you my
friend I'm doing fine so is there gonna
be a special Bryce Harper corner or does
everybody just go from the Winter
Meetings to his house is there shuttle I
mean what's the setup here in Vegas you
might heard the rumor that Bryce lives
in Vegas where the Winter Meetings are
in his town in the year that he's a free
agent you just can't make this stuff up
I I would say it's safe to assume that
Scott Boras has been collecting every
Bell and every whistle that could be
collected and the brace Harper story
lines will be swirling whether he signs
at the Winter Meetings is a whole nother
story
but we'll be talking about him non-stop
well I had him on the show a couple
weeks ago Scott Boras and I asked him if
he's gonna wait for Machado to go first
he says those are two totally unrelated
issues do you believe that no they're
not one is gonna set the market for the
other you know Scott has this ability to
create a bidding war in which the war is
not necessarily team versus team but
team's bidding against this mythical
record that he believes Bryce needs to
said Bryce needs to be the highest-paid
player in the game either measured
against the highest dollars per year or
the biggest total contract with
Giancarlo Stanton deal or ideally in
Scotts world both and even if there's
only one team in the bidding I'm
convinced that Scott will find a way to
have that team did against that dynamic
but the other side of the coin is Dan
Lozano thinks the same stuff about many
and so of course they're linked but I
mean so what what do you think the
market is for both let's start with
Bryce Harper because we're hearing that
Magic Johnson's flying out with the
Dodgers contingent to go hang out in
Vegas you know that was the the Yahoo
Sports report the other day that the
Dodgers shot down that magic
even personally shot down and I would
not count out the Dodgers you I mean you
can't write but I you know I've also had
people inside the Dodgers tell me in
within the last count of your so we are
out of the ten year nine figure contract
business well they're not going to get
Bryce Harper without signing them for at
least ten years and at least nine
figures that's safe to say right so we
will we'll see about that part of it the
Dodgers have played it very coy Lee but
it's such a perfect fit it's certainly
something to watch okay so how many
teams you think are in on on Bryce
Harper right well I mean at Yahoo Sports
report by Jeff Passan and Tim Brown said
upward of a dozen teams as you know as
I've called around asked about that
since I would take the under on that I
think it's really a much tighter circle
I think the Phillies are clearly in it
the White Sox are clearly in it the
Nationals are lurking but it's more
challenging for them now after the
Patrick Korbin deal and then the many
Yankees are totally monitoring this I
don't think they're bidding but they're
they don't they don't need him I mean
you've got you've got in your outfield
obviously you've already got that three
hundred million dollar player or
whatever else is left on on Stanton's
contract judge is a generational talent
that the whole fan base is head over
heels in love with you're not putting
him in centerfield
I mean they it's so Wow and and and on
that front too I don't think they need
Machado either I don't I don't care that
didi Gregorius might not play next year
I mean know how many people come back
from Tommy John surgery and throw 100
miles an hour I mean yeah I'm serious
get through the season you'll need to
commit three hundred million dollars to
to Manny Machado if you're the Yankees
but I guess they will do with them I'm
with you I think Manny is actually the
better fit you know there's there a lot
of parallels here to Aaron Boone gets
hurt playing basketball and next thing
you know Alex Rodriguez is a Yankee you
know you could concoct that story
and mani has communicated to the Yankees
from what I've heard that he would like
to be a Yankee and again they're clearly
monitoring this are they are they going
to pay him 300 million dollars I don't
see that depends I think how badly he
wants to be a Yankee but the fact that
he could start out playing short and
when DD comes back could slide over to
third makes him really an ideal fit for
them in terms of just a baseball part of
it the rest of it is a whole nother
story so what what do you think happens
with these two guys when it's all said
and done if you read a crystal ball
Jason right now we're all just guessing
this service market is really just
getting going for both of them if I were
going to guess
I predict Harper to the Phillies Machado
to the Yankees but yeah I'm first off
I'm never right the second I second
anything is possible this really what
does in the early stages of this believe
it or not five weeks in the free agency
Jason stark MLB network's coverage again
from Las Vegas beginning this Sunday at
8 p.m. Eastern Time and also covering
the winter meetings for the athletic
who's on the other tier who are we not
paying attention to that's out there
that has a ton of people chasing after
and can actually be a difference maker
do you think Jason well I mean now that
Patrick Korbin has signed and you know
once Machado and Harper signed I think
we're definitely that neck and is that
next tier but Michael Brantley is a
really intriguing player Jay you have a
starting pitching market starting to
move I think Jay Happ will find pretty
quickly he's probably the next Domino to
fall there and then you know you got all
the Boras clients who will just hang
around because that's what Scott does
then the other guy to watch Craig
Kimbrel Greek temples one of the
greatest closes who ever lived not
coming off a great October looking for
six years and and probably historic
money I don't know if he gets that but I
mean that's a difference making player
what are the Diamondbacks doing Jason
here I mean Corbin winds up going to the
National
and Goldschmidt gets traded to the
Cardinals what's going on with Arizona
here well I mean I'm sure this is
discouraging for anyone who cares about
that team but I also think it's safe to
say that had they not won as many games
as they want in 2017 and you know and
made it to the postseason then they
would have done this a year ago but
didn't feel like they could do it then
but this has been this has been in the
wind hovering over this entire season we
knew they weren't gonna be able to
resign Patrick Korbin and it was clear
that if they got a deal they liked they
would trade Paul Goldschmidt they might
not be done right there's there's
certainly other pieces there they'd love
to move Greinke I think they would move
Robby ray I mean 14 goes in first place
for five months this is discouraging for
people in Arizona and for the industry
as a whole but it's where we are so
what's going on with the shift Jason I
read that in the athletic and your in
your column in the athletic and as you
know I despise it I think it is
absolutely the root cause as to why and
at that results either in a strikeout
walk or a home run these days every
manager that I've had on this show Cora
and Roberts and Hinch just to name three
that I've asked about it Melvin none of
them say that they would they be up for
having it legislated out and yet
according to you it looks like that the
Commissioner is going to try and get a
rule pass to get the shift out of the
game here correct well I mean I'm you
know I wrote this piece the other day in
the athletic and it really did blow up
the response has been incredible and it
was generated by the fact that during
the owners meeting I think that was
three weeks ago the competition
committee met and there was an a really
surprisingly strong amount of support
shown within that committee for doing
something to limit shifts you know
they're not a lot of front office people
on that committee they're you know so
you have to keep that in mind there's
been an incredible amount of fun
office pushback that I've heard since I
wrote this piece but there's definite
interest in it and then so the question
is with players agree to it I think they
would we know that you know what half
the players are hitters they would all
agree to it Joey Gallo tweeted after I
wrote that story this is all I want for
Christmas a lot of pictures don't like
it even though the data would show it
helps them so the I think this is
something you could get the players to
approve and then the other question is
how much would it help there you know
what they're looking for is more action
more guys running around the bases
I had sports info solutions crunch these
numbers yeah there's no doubt that the
batting average on ground balls short
line drives that are now going into the
shift in her outs would go up 50 points
you definitely have more baserunners and
more action and so it's gonna be a
fascinating conversation yeah I read
some of the numbers earlier in the show
Jason and it's just it's not as if the
shift has obviously the shifts been
around for a long time I mean you could
you could you could put the word
baseball shift and Ted Williams in there
and you could see a you know like what
looks to me like a newspaper graphic if
you will from back in the 50s and the
40's of a shift against Ted Williams and
and and so it's been around forever but
it is exploded I mean it's absurd Scott
Boras again was on a couple weeks ago he
said it's biased against lefties and his
point is absolutely well taken in the
point that you cannot have four guys on
the right side on the left side of
second just for the mere fact nobody's
covering first in the same way that you
could do it against a lefty having four
guys on the right side of second it's so
what do you think the your best guess
would be the language it's C yeah that
that's a hard one you know I asked a lot
of questions about this and I I would
say all that they have committed to so
far is to in fitters on the left side
second base and to in fitters on the
right side of second base but would
would you be allowed to put in theaters
in the outfield
they haven't gotten that far yet would
you be would you see a the shortstop or
second baseman three inches from second
base and then charging over to the other
side of the bag as the pitch is thrown
it depends how the rule is written there
are a lot of ways you can go I had
people from from teams ask me how are we
defining an infielder you know suppose I
decide to make my shortstop in a theater
and I play him in the short range field
this would be very hard to word and very
hard to enforce I don't think anybody
disputes that part but here's my thing
rich I love baseball I'm for anything
that makes the game better more
entertaining something that more people
love and talk about and all of this
should be part of the conversation
that's really why I wrote the piece
let's start the conversation all right
name is Pete Rose gonna be signing
autographs in Vegas I mean this this we
see him at the Bellagio you know and
that I mean he's always been I mean I'm
kind of being serious what do you think
that I have not checked the schedule but
he signed autographs during Hall of Fame
induction week so I would Winter
Meetings we'd be any different when
their meetings in Vegas that's an
interesting choice it really really has
been for baseball Jason thank you enjoy
it has it really it's interesting I come
back ten years ago well let's change a
little bit the Blue Man Group I think
still there though a 9-year 220 million
dollars yes Scott Boras Cirque du Soleil
is those two shows every single night
good to chat with you Jason
you bet Sam you that's Jason stark at
Jason STI follow him on Twitter you
should too his great stuff the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience